GETS IT INSIDE Mia:  THE SHOT F
SAVED,  QUITE TEXTBOOK.
BUTTERFLIES THERE.
FRONT, PUCK
LOOSE, HERTL!
NOW WE HAVE
OVERAGGRESSIVE DEFENSIVELY.
A BIT OF A SUB SCORES!
TIMO MEIER, THE POWER PLAY DS
UP ON HIS BACK AND, RIGHT THE W
AND MOMENT TO PLAY IN. CE.
STARTED IS.
SAVED BY HILL.
HE HAS TO OSS, SHOT
THE SECOND.
DETROIT, LOOKING FOR THE FIRST
GOAL OF  THEY
HAVE TO CHOOSE WHICH HAND TO
USE.
ON THAT, REBOUNEUTRAL
ICE.
HRONEK , THE IS TO WORK.!
NICK LEDDY, THE HARMLESS
ENTRANCE FINDS THROW IT.
HILL IS CAUGHT BY  CONTACT MADE
HERE COMES A SHOT
THE HEAD.
GIVING CHASE,  HERTL HAS A SHOT
ROUGH THE THIRD
PERIOD AT THE S.A.P. FIFISHOT,
SECONDS HERE.
A CHANGE.
THEN IF HE LOSES THE DRAW, NOW
YOU'VE GOT YOUIS IN!